experience marketing services conducted
a rolling survey
to determine whether there any patterns
between politics
and food eye-rolling surveys where you
got gather information over a long
period of time
and there are some interesting findings
which we've got a budget the first what
is conservative versus liberal
food chain so this is where
conservatives by tonight conservative
or love all charlie's Cracker Barrel
that one doesn't surprise me
they like home town buffet what is an
excellent
pop over after I dot Papa Murphy's
LongHorn Steakhouse okay so the same
these are meaty kinda things hearty
party is where the Liberals eating
California Pizza Kitchen that socialist
yeah
Macaroni Grill Ruth Chris Steak House
sounds kinda pricey on the border that
makes and
PF Changs everybody likes a lil no
change Asian food
next up conservative versus liberal fast
food chain
so the Conservatives they're digging
kristall
I actually don't know what that is
murder I don't know across the river and
I'm a little burgers yeah it kind of
like White Castle
okay had the exact same thing as why I
look at it like a thought-out
there about what a burger that's mostly
down south side
ataxia whatever shellac skis Delhi
which also I don't know that one where
am I i hella I have no the Sharma
chick-fil-a that one doesn't surprise me
and they like Steak N Shake which is big
in the midwest
where the Liberals in their facebook
Arbonne par
a dirty rebel girl taking an airport
yeah
water bread water bread trip ole and you
know because portable is supposed to be
a
you know relatively healthy way as far
as that goes occurred over which is
basically in Tripoli knock up
blimpie I thought that was interesting
they like it more than subway or
with the Quiznos and a Starbucks week or
so that the Liberals are we hanging out
at Starbucks
I want more on supermarket chain change
this is where the Conservatives are gone
they're going to Randalls Weis markets
Piggly Wiggly
broke Shires and boomtown I
interestingly that so liberal broke
Shires brookie
my Berkshire russia rather me go back
yeah
going I want to dissect so I these first
the
what piggly wiggly I know about how they
have been to any these first four
put and being on the east coast yeah i i
the rest resolve the matter how are
these rather
midwestern other delivered on Piggly
Wiggly you've got a winner here where
the Liberals guide you in their food
wrapping
I where a not being liberal
all food whole paycheck withholding a
trader Joe that's where I do much to my
shopping
Fred Meyer Acme and state way so there
are some
interesting I think we can glean some
interesting stuff that is this
do you think you can get more
information about what people believe
politically by this kind of stuff
them pot by polling them on actual
politics I think there might be
something to that liberals are if they
are much healthier
is that going back to the rate is a good
now their oaths or no why
healthier stuff yeah more vegetarian
yeah they're
do I mean I think that if you were some
sort of advertising your consumer
marketing company and you wanted to be
sneaky about the way that you reach your
consumer
yes you could go this route but I don't
think you're going to glean more
information
about somebody's political views than
asking them point blank what are your
political views I don't think that
there's some old here your like a weird
now everybody shops a hole for me that
way
every way architecture it I think that
this is a
bullshit study point-blank this is the
bullshit study I remember once doing
a maybe with the Young Turks maybe it
was the point i remember i at a roller
being on the show with us and
talking about maybe was even the common
room and talking about a similar study
that was like
I can tell your political persuasion
based on the alcohol that you drink
and like know what you can tell us where
I live in the country
and the true there there's a high
correlation between
this type of food consumption and
regional different that yeah and there's
also a high correlation between those
regional differences
and political affiliation and now those
things are being completed
carry this is a hundred percent wire
brush let us know because I'm not always
told on these studies but I think the
very interesting that they get out there
to look at the Buncombe a little bit on
that there's also a high correlation
between people that wear Wranglers and
people that wear
I don't know J Brand Jeans and their
political persuasion it because the
where you live
at J Brand that can be California if
California New York it's going to be a
higher scale client shop that
you know North Stormers active Avenue
and Wrangler Jeans like I'm from Texas
I know that this is going to be
something that people in the south are
going to be more likely to wear them or
a fashion statement that you see in this
out
and so it's going to be more likely that
those people are conservative and
they're probably gonna drinks a whiskey
instead of wine do you think that that
spot
you're at war with the incentive vodka
for example so I think they're really
just
regional differences in people because
that where are you going to the movies
somebody's restaurant so take advantage
of those racial differences in our their
purpose because
I know and I felt their Cracker Barrel
everywhere everywhere and I have friends
who refused to go to them because when
you walk in it's like there's do this
music playing
their path that they John 3:16 all these
Bible though and they just feel
uncomfortable so they won't go
underground rave
yeah they make character
really hard really do here with this
conversation that we have a lot of times
about
voting with their dollar which i think
that that you know the big chick-fil-a
debate with a mean maybe I'm just a
sucker and I grew up in Texas and I
really like chick-fil-a
I apologize I am NOT homophobic you know
the rail
but I like homophobic chicken K really
good and yeah
here's here's part iv: be issue I think
is that it's
the deck is stacked against a lot of
consumers in this country and if we
chase the money
alternately we're gonna get something we
don't like ultimately organic and
everything that we are polarized about
and that were politically against
and idle I get it if you're somebody who
can take the time to do your due
diligence and do I love your research
and pick up where you wanna shop
based on your political a affiliations
that's great and more power to you but I
don't like it when people get high and
mighty about telling other people that
they should do that to you because like
sign up fucking time in the day day to
research
every single thing I spend my money on
yeah it gets confusing I mean
you know are left to right late daughter
and a Bonner going to prison right now
for tax evasion and
Italy and like if you're against that
you know it's it goes from the top 20
to the bottom it goes from high to low
is a dramatic raid a dark corner
all the time alone every night for going
after stopping anywhere guarded gas at
BP
exactly and somebody's me when it's like
it any better to get gas at exotic no
era
companies making a decision if you're
shopping atm a multinational
conglomerate
probably that they're making money on
the backs of other people in this is a
big difficulty in capital with the fight
yes you can I generally up to eat at in
and out
over these other choices because I ate
healthier for and be I do appreciate
their corporate values a little bit more
and I'd much rather go to a mom-and-pop
then go to a big change
but there are times when I'm stock I
still have to put gas in my car right
now call it. we live in we all make
different choices an interesting
the BP thing you know the oil spill
obviously whichever which they were
completely at fault for
most people were boycotting their gas
stations which are franchised so you
weren't even hurting
the corporation the conglomerate you
were hurting the individual franchisees
which had nothing to do with any the
safety thing at chick-fil-a
it's on a totally franchise and so you
see like the chick-fil-a here in West
Hollywood
is not a homophobic chick-fil-a at all
people are boycotting they're like
where on the West Hollywood likely it
worked here later healthcare
and that the problem you know is that we
don't know all the ins and outs a lot of
these deals are done kinda in the dark
in the shadow in that
the records aren't available to the
consumer and taking political action
via your food choices i think is a good
idea
but I also don't think it's always
reasonable
idea alright people there you go we
don't know everything about what
in our food and who's selling author
we're doing the best we can